[Música]
la rebelión de Wagner en Rusia y su
marcha a Moscú contra las fuerzas
militares del kremlin duró menos de 24
horas pero es un episodio que marca la
guerra y también a los 22 años del poder
de Putin de un lado sacó a Jenny y a
varios sino a todos sus mercenarios de
Ucrania todo comenzó en la noche del
viernes 23 de junio cuando pri gojin
afirmó que las tropas rusas habían
bombardeado a sus milicianos y anunció
una marcha militar desde la ciudad rusa
de rostov ondon hacia
moscúrate hay que poner fin al mal que
soporta la cúpula militar del país
descuidan la vida de los soldados
olvidaron la palabra justicia y nosotros
se la devolveremos por lo tanto los que
destruyeron a nuestros muchachos hoy los
que destruyeron decenas muchas decenas
de miles de Vidas de soldados rusos
serán castigados
Cuál era el objetivo de la guerra
era necesaria para la autopromoción de
un puñado de bastardos para demostrar lo
fuerte que es su ejército para que shoyú
pudiera ser nombrado Mariscal
Putin no tardó en responder y tildó al
que antes era su gran Aliado militar
como un traidor
cualquier agitación interna es una
amenaza mortal para nuestro estado para
nosotros como nación esto es un golpe
para Rusia y para nuestro pueblo y
nuestras acciones para proteger a la
patria de tal amenazas serán duras
todos aquellos que deliberadamente se
embarcaron en el camino de la tradición
que prepararon una rebelión Armada se
embarcaron en el camino del chantaje y
métodos terroristas sufrieron un castigo
Inevitable responderán ante la ley y
ante nuestro pueblo
tan solo horas después de estas palabras
la oficina de prensa de la presidencia
de velarus anunció que con el aval del
kremlin había mediado un pacto para que
pregojin detuviera su avanzada y se
exiliara en el país que Hasta ahora ha
sido el Aliado fiel de Rusia con La
Rebeldía frenada Putin emitió otra
locución en la que agradeció a las
tropas evitar una guerra civil y les
ofreció a Los mercenarios de Wagner
unirse a las fuerzas militares rusas
hoy ustedes tienen la oportunidad de
continuar su servicio para Rusia
firmando un contrato con el Ministerio
de defensa u otras estructuras militares
o policiales o para volver con su
familia y sus allegados los que quieran
pueden irse a belarus la promesa que
hice se cumplirá
agradezco a los combatientes y
comandantes del grupo Wagner que tomaron
la única decisión correcta y no buscaron
un derramamiento de sangre fraticida se
detuvieron en el último límite
está en velarus como lo dijo este martes
el presidente de Alexander lucasenco
la gente no entiende que también
adoptamos un enfoque pragmático si sus
comandantes vienen a nosotros y nos
ayudan que esto es experiencia escuche
están a la vanguardia escuadrones de
asalto Ellos nos dirán lo que es
importante en este momento
nos reuniremos con ellos y Tendremos que
pedirles insistentemente que no se
dediquen a nada más que sus comandantes
se reúnan con los nuestros en los campos
de entrenamiento demuestren expliquen
sus tácticas sus armamentos Cómo llevar
a cabo operaciones ofensivas Y
defensivas esto no tiene precio Esto es
lo que necesitamos tomar del personal de
Wagner
pero la historia aún no termina y quedan
varias dudas en el aire por ejemplo que
hubo detrás del motín fue una muestra de
las rupturas internas y un acto
desesperado de prigo de sus
enfrentamientos constantes con el
Ministerio de defensa ruso o todo es una
estrategia planeada por Moscú para
fortalecer su presencia militar en de
larus para analizar este tema hoy en el
debate nos acompaña desde Portugal
Marcos Farías Ferreira profesor de
estudios rusos y posoviéticos en la
universidad de Lisboa y desde Argentina
se conecta Andrea servín doctor en
ciencias políticas analiza internacional
y presidente del Tin Tank regional Cris
bienvenidos aquí al debate y a ustedes
nuestra audiencia Los invito a que dejen
sus comentarios sus preguntas y todo lo
que opinan a través de las redes
sociales con el numeral el debate f24 en
Twitter Facebook e Instagram estamos
como arroba franz24 raya al piso es y yo
estoy como arroba María claguirre además
quiero saludar a quienes nos están
escuchando en este momento en nuestros
podcast a través de las plataformas de
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Marcos quiero comenzar con usted esta
discusión con una pregunta básica para
detonar el debate y es cuál cree usted
que es el motivo de esta rebelión de
bagner Hola María Clara
yo creo que hay varios motivos hay
varios niveles de análisis que podemos
utilizar para encontrar el sentido de
esta Aventura o rebelión o levantamiento
en primer lugar hay un motivo muy micro
que tiene que ver con el negocio de las
armas de la guerra
alrededor del grupo Wagner y de prey
goji o sea en los últimos meses semanas
el grupo estuvo involucrado en la
batalla de
backmuth y hubo un conjunto de
dificultades logísticas
prigon estuvo buscando
negociar con con el kremlin con la
cúpula militar rusa el envío de armas de
municiones y sobre todo la continuidad
del Contract del contrato con con el
kremlin que le da la posibilidad de
establecerse como una empresa privada
del sector militar y estas tensiones con
el kremlin se estaban adensando de forma
que se estaba ya anunciando el final del
contrato del kremlin con el grupo y o
sea le quedaba muy poco a pregon En ese
sentido de negociar de
garantizar la continuidad de su negocio
por lo tanto hay este motivo muy micro
del negocio de garantizar su negocio
Pero por otro lado también hay tensiones
alrededor de estrategia de la guerra en
en Ucrania y en todo el debate sobre la
efectividad de la guerra del mando
militar ruso una motivación y una
discusión que se mezcla con el motivo
más micro del negocio Pero yo creo que
el motivo micro es muy significativo
porque
estaba en causa y continúa estando en
causa la continuidad de este negocio que
es muy rentable y muy significativo en
la guerra moderna usted habla de el
negocio Y a propósito el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin dijo que el estado ruso
había financiado en los últimos años a
esta milicia y a este grupo paramilitar
Wagner le quiero dar la bienvenida a
Andrés y preguntarle si usted está de
acuerdo con esta opinión de que el
negocio está detrás de todo y si es así
no le comería más a pregon seguir siendo
un Aliado de Putin
Muchas gracias por la invitación Buenas
noches efectivamente yo creo que en el
medio hay un negocio que estaba a punto
de descarrilarse en el sentido de los
intereses de piriguayo en eventualmente
porque había una propuesta así de
renovar un contrato pero que
subordinara a los altos mandos militares
a la fuerza Wagner y eso realmente
generaba mucha resistencia Por qué
Porque básicamente Wagner adquirió una
reputación y una proyección en su
capacidad militar muy importante que
además Tiene efectos sobre la sociedad
civil en Rusia en general no nos
olvidemos que pregocen ha utilizado muy
bien uno de los canales con menos
restricciones en las redes sociales que
es Telegram Y en segundo lugar eso desde
luego yo concuerdo con el colega que
había otro nivel de preocupación que
tenía que ver con las tensiones e
intrigas dentro más que nada entre
bagner y los altos mandos militares que
tiene que ver también con las divisiones
de de las distintas fuerzas de seguridad
y a quien respondía Wagner como tal
originariamente recordemos que Wagner
respondía al gnu
Gro que es el espionaje militar y que
había convertido a Wagner un instrumento
ofensivo digamos de inteligencia
ofensiva en otros ámbitos y después lo
proyectó Ucrania Entonces los dos
elementos están pero yo creo que hay un
tercer elemento que hay que tener en
cuenta que a través de la reputación
adquirida y el poder adquirido en en el
frente de batalla lo que
es aparece fundamentalmente es una
dimensión política una capacidad de
proyección política de pregocen y ahí
empiezan toda una serie de interrogantes
si detrás de esto no había también
alguna intencionalidad política de
responder a unas demandas de algunos
sectores mucho más radicales
nacionalistas en Rusia de que la guerra
se profundizara a pesar de las
declaraciones previas de
asociada con los sectores más
nacionalistas que inclusive cuestionan
Cómo estás llevando la guerra hablemos
de ese segundo nivel que ustedes han
planteado y es la resistencia de Wagner
de tener que responder al Ministerio de
defensa Ruso y es que como ustedes lo
han dicho
a través de Telegram criticaba de manera
constante a esta cartera y por ejemplo
denunciaba que el ministro de defensa
y también el jefe del Estado Mayor del
ejército que comanda las operaciones en
Ucrania les estoy hablando de Valery
los criticaba constantemente e incluso
los tildaba de ser corruptos e
inoperantes porque decía que no le
enviaban armas suficientes para defender
por ejemplo que ha sido uno de los
fuertes donde se ha concentrado la
guerra y Aparentemente
en este segundo nivel que ustedes hablan
se genera esta atención o se lleva al
límite cuando Putin A mediados de junio
dice que las tropas de Wagner deben
quedar al servicio de las fuerzas
militares rusas
se revela Entonces por una de las tantas
razones para evitar esto pero se puede
decir Marcos que al final pierde la
batalla Porque después de esta rebelión
de menos de un día ahora Putin decidió
que las milicias de Wagner deberían
entrar a las fuerzas militares no es así
yo creo que sí creo que
hay una atención que llega a un punto
fundamental
Puede que pregocen haya pensado que
tenía más apoyos dentro de la cúpula
político militar rusa es una historia
que es difícil de dilucidar en este en
este momento que está relacionada con su
retirada para algunos prematura a 200 a
tan solo 200 km de Moscú pero yo creo
que de alguna manera esa retirada tiene
que estar relacionada con la falta de
apoyos
ese tercer nivel que habíamos subrayado
hace hace poco puede ser significativo
pero en la ausencia de esa de ese apoyo
puede que se haya como
desmembrado yo quiero recordar algo
también muy importante es que
sí esta marcha o este esta rebelión
hubiera sido tan importante y estuviera
tan
arraigada en las tensiones luchas
internas seguramente habrían aparecido
grupúsculos o una parte de oposición
extra parlamentaria por ejemplo o
incluso algún alguna tomada de posición
por parte de sectores de de seguridad de
Rusia Pero esto De hecho no no pasó no
hubo no hubo ninguna personalidad del
ejército fuera del ejército no
aparecieron los famosos grupos que
habían hecho incursiones en la zona de
velgot por ejemplo en la semana
anteriores y grupos que habían sido
asociados a una oposición anti Putin o
sea
yo creo que
se vio solo en esta
oposición al sobre todo al Ministerio de
defensa de defensa Ruso y no tuvo más
remedio que negociar una salida
más o menos digna y que
defendiera sus intereses básicos que
todavía no sabemos Cuál es Cuáles son no
sabemos todavía que parte de su negocio
está garantizada cómo lo va a prolongar
en belarruz y
que perspectiva de vida tiene pero es
cierto que su negocio es muy importante
tanto para Rusia por ejemplo en África
como para pelarrus
Usted cree que Wagner se acaba aquí
yo creo que no De ninguna manera
primero porque Wagner es una franquicia
Wagner en Europa o sea en Rusia en
Ucrania o en biela rusa ahora de ahora
en adelante es una cosa es un grupo con
un mando específico en África está
operando de otra manera de acuerdo con
otra lógica y con otro tipo de
articulación con los intereses
exteriores del Estado Ruso y estoy
seguro que o sea estoy seguro porque
también ya esto ya fue dicho ha estado
lo están lo están diciendo desde desde
el fin de semana que Wagner Va a
continuar en África porque es un recurso
fundamental para los intereses rusos en
Mali en la República centroafricana por
ejemplo en la estrategia de tensión con
las potencias europeas la gran duda es
que rol va a tener Wagner en belarrus
por ejemplo y en la Guerra de Ucrania
será que
Wagner va a servir como una forma de
dividir las atenciones de las fuerzas
ucranianas entre el norte y el sur del
territorio será que el Wagner va a tener
su grupo va a tener algún alguna función
logística militar en la continuación de
la guerra eso todavía no lo sabemos y
justo esta respuesta que usted nos da
nos da pie a pensar y a debatir sobre
esta hipótesis que ha surgido de que en
realidad Putin está detrás de todo y que
es una estrategia para llevar a los
milicianos de Wagner a territorio de
velarios que además es un país mucho más
cercano de los países occidentales como
Polonia que están respaldando a Ucrania
Andrés Usted cree en esta hipótesis
bueno es una lectura posible que corrió
como un rumor inicialmente
particularmente en las redes y que ahora
pareciera haberse confirmado porque el
secretario general de la otan
stoltenberg ha dicho que está mirando
con preocupación el desplazamiento de
Wagner a de la Rusia y hacia la frontera
con Ucrania la frontera norte de Ucrania
en un movimiento que de estar a 200
kilómetros de Moscú terminando a 90 km
de Kia Y esto es bastante llamativo hay
un término para este tipo de operaciones
en la jerga militar que en ruso que es
más quirozca es decir encubrir una
operación con otras cosas y de hecho
personalmente creo que esto es una
posibilidad muy importante
reafirmada Por lo que dijo lucasenco en
la misma en el mismo fragmento discurso
que ustedes han presentado en donde
tiene grandes expectativas con respecto
a incorporar asimilar a la a los wagners
en en en todo caso en la estructura
militar este y en las fuerzas armadas
bielorrusas Ahora me parece que las
alarmas han sonado en ese sentido ya en
occidente y aquí entramos en otro tipo
de contradicciones Porque también las
alarmas habían sonado Aparentemente los
servicios de inteligencia de Estados
Unidos y de Gran Bretaña habían
detectado los preparativos de este Push
porrigoyen el miércoles pasado y no
informaron para nada de esta situación
de tal manera que yo creo que si
consideramos que eso sucedió en serio y
que la inteligencia británica
estadounidense estaba enterada yo estoy
absolutamente seguro que también la
inteligencia rusa estaba enterada pero
usted planteado por lo menos no descarta
la hipótesis de que esta fuera una
misión para encubrir otra pero del otro
lado la rebelión de Wagner implicó un
alto costo para el kremlin Y es que
mostró como Jean puso contra la pared un
poco a Putin O al menos afirmó que tenía
las tropas para combatir al ejército
Ruso y no solo eso sino que se tomó las
bases militares de por lo menos tres
ciudades en medio de su marcha hacia
Moscú usted si cree que sea un precio a
pagar a cambio de una supuesta misión
para encubrir otra Bueno lo que estamos
viendo y estoy lo mencionó en algún
momento es que no se ha fragmentado como
esperaba occidente y eventualmente lo
señaló el mismo Celeste lo que es el
poder en Rusia Putin sigue en control y
la toma de tres ciudades en realidad no
aparejó muchas bajas y de hecho la razón
por la cual Aparentemente prigorren se
había detenido en su avance era para no
causar bajas sino derramar sangre rusa
pero lo cierto es que también esto ha
servido a Putin para otro elemento que
se pierda de vista y también lo menciona
él en su último discurso Y es que esto
le da la oportunidad de depurar y
perseguir Y purgar a todos aquellos que
eventualmente podían haber reaccionado
apoyando un Push de este tipo y esto
también es un elemento muy importante
porque va a implicar un incremento de
los mecanismos de control de represión a
futuro en Rusia Marcos Cómo cree usted
que queda la imagen del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin después de que llama
traidor
promete toda la fuerza para disolver el
motín y luego simplemente lo deja ir a
velarus
bueno en primer lugar yo creo que todos
los regímenes regímenes todos los
estados están sujetos a esta posibilidad
de presiones detenciones internas y
durante una guerra mucho más O sea no no
creo que debamos ver en esto un hecho
extraordinario que nos diga algo sobre
la debilidad o la vulnerabilidad
específica del Estado ruso dicho esto
otra cosa importante es tener en cuenta
el contexto el estado ruso es un estado
todavía muy débil y vulnerable en los
últimos 30 años la transición
posoviética
ha acumulado debilidades y fragilidades
económicas logísticas militares que
Putin ha empezado a transformar justo al
final de su segundo mandato o sea Rusia
es en recuperación después de los años
90 trágicos después de un impacto
fundamental de esta terapia de shock
impuesta por las organizaciones
internacionales para adaptarse a la
economía global por lo tanto yo creo que
lo más importante es saber cómo contesta
Putin como reacciona a esto que es
normal en cualquier régimen no O sea
como va a intentar recuperar su imagen
Porque obvio que esto Esto es un desafío
fundamental también asumando y a su
imagen de autócrata y de padre de la
patria lo podríamos poner así y creo que
durante estos dos últimos días ya
estamos viendo cómo va Cómo va la cosa o
sea con una ceremonia patriótica para
empezar
con el conocimiento de Los Héroes con la
evocación de una guerra civil que se
pudo evitar con la evocación de los
muertos que no hubo y por lo tanto
también con creo yo con algunas
decisiones en a través de las cuales el
mando político militar va a incorporar
las críticas de prey goji por ejemplo
al transcurso de la guerra o sea una
adaptación una
adaptación a las críticas y una
recuperación de esa imagen Y sobre todo
una contestación a la narrativa
occidental que está subrayando esto
todos estos días y lo va a continuar
haciendo de la fragilidad de Putin o sea
va el Putin va a contrarrestar va a
intentar contrarrestar esta narrativa
occidental pero usted ahí tiene una
porque primero nos muestra que esta
rebelión de Wagner no significa una
muestra de vulnerabilidades dentro del
Estado ruso luego nos dice que el estado
ruso es un estado frágil en recuperación
luego de la era soviética y como usted
bien lo menciona el kremlin ha
desplegado una serie de actos para
mostrarse no solo Putin hizo dos
locuciones pregrabadas sino también este
acto y esta ceremonia para patriótica de
la que usted nos habla y el ministro de
defensa
publicó un video en el que se muestra
junto a las tropas en Ucrania todo esto
justo después de la rebelión Usted cree
entonces que golpea o no la imagen del
crimen no es una contradicción yo creo
lo que lo que mi opinión es que no es
excepcional lo que pasó es algo que
puede pasar sobre todo durante una
guerra o sea es un riesgo que está
corriendo el mando político militar ruso
desde el principio de la de la guerra
pero que por ejemplo
hubo tuvo que
contemplar en otros momentos el estado
ruso ha estado sujeto a este tipo y otro
y otros tipos de desafíos por ejemplo la
guerra en chechenia la ola de terrorismo
del principio de este de este siglo
la guerra de Siria también la
implicación en la guerra de Siria es un
riesgo que la cúpula política militar y
personalmente Putin creen que vale la
pena para recuperar su estatuto de
grande de Gran potencia y sobre todo
esta guerra que muchos dicen que es un
mal cálculo un cálculo poco racional de
las capacidades de Rusia es está visto
por el kremlin precisamente al revés o
sea como una reacción
para prevenir lo que entienden que es
inevitable O sea la integración de
Ucrania en las estructuras euroatlántica
otan en la Unión Europea o sea es
preventivo por lo tanto yo creo que es
más importante que poner toda nuestra
atención en la excepcionalidad de del
puig de del desafío debemos mirar como
Putin y la cúpula militar responden
contestan y para ese desafío para
fortalecer su posición viendo esto como
una oportunidad estábamos diciendo eso
hace hace poco cuando hablábamos de
Wagner en vela Ruz Yo creo que es no ha
estado preparado para eso pero están
viendo en eso una oportunidad en este
momento y para el transcurso de la
guerra Andrés coincide usted en este
punto en que la rebelión puede ser una
oportunidad para Vladimir Putin para
mostrarse fuerte y como cataloga usted
la reacción que ha tenido el kremlin y
especialmente el Ministerio de defensa
bueno primero tenemos que constatar una
cosa que es importante y usted lo señaló
nadie ha sido removido de los altos
mandos que cuestionaba privoyen al
contrario se han mostrado según se ha
mostrado en un documental en el frente
eracimos no sé si haya tenido algún tipo
de declaración pero ninguno de ellos ha
sido removido el segundo punto que me
parece muy importante tener en cuenta es
que Putin ha aprovechado para insistir
en algo que es un tema particularmente
delicado para los rusos qué es lo que te
ven los rusos no solamente a partir de
la perestroika sino también de la guerra
civil a principios del siglo pasado e
inclusive del siglo 17 en adelante la la
transición de una Dinastía a otra Qué es
la inestabilidad del país eso es lo que
más les preocupa a la mayor parte de la
gente y Putin ha mandado un mensaje muy
claro el país está estable está todos
estamos Unidos van a ser castigados
eventualmente aquellos que pudieron
traicionarnos Pero él insiste por las
referencias históricas mismas a las que
hace en sus discurso insiste en el tema
de que la estabilidad está garantizada
por lo tanto está más bien reforzando su
posición más que debilitándola ustedes
entonces coinciden en que quizás uno de
los ganadores de todo este episodio
puede ser paradójicamente el mismo Putin
porque ayuda a fortalecer las ideas que
ha defendido de que su país está Unido
Andrés quién entonces podría catalogarse
como del lado de los perdedores pueden
estar dentro de ellos y el Jenny prey
goji
yo tengo la impresión de que la
trayectoria de prigorren en Rusia no ha
terminado con su desplazamiento a
Bielorrusia Yo creo que tiene esto es
una historia que va a seguir
desarrollándose y evolucionando Y
seguramente pregocen va a tener un papel
en ella mayor o menor en este momento
desde luego todo se ha calmado en
términos de su desplazamiento a
Bielorrusia pero no nos olvidemos que
prigo no es solamente el propietario de
Wagner sino es todo un una corporación
con distintas actividades Incluyendo los
trolls que afectaron la campaña de
Estados Unidos hace siete años
todos los mecanismos de desinformación
con los que se maneja sus inversiones en
términos de las fuerzas mercenarias que
están en África al punto tal que estaban
por abrir una oficina en México bueno
todo esto implica un conglomerado muy
importante que ha ido construyendo
prigogen y que no se va de la noche a la
mañana porque tenga Aparentemente un
revés en el plano estrictamente militar
yo creo que hay una confusión porque
Wagner no es Gregorio no es solamente
Wagner y Wagner no solamente consiste en
sus operaciones en Ucrania y tal como
usted lo dice es una red mucho más
amplia que incluso
proveyendo los los alimentos para el
kremlin y por eso se le conocía como el
chef de Putin y también suministra los
alimentos para las fuerzas armadas rusas
y para los colegios estatales entre
otros Marcos en este sentido Entonces
cómo queda esta balanza Porque si luego
de esta rebelión y de este hecho al que
los medios tanta atención le hemos
puesto gana Putin pregojin No termina
perdiendo del todo cómo queda entonces
Ucrania y sus aliados occidentales y
cuál es el balance que usted hace de
este hecho
yo creo que no no podemos mirar esto
como una simple suma de perdedores
ganadores es más una situación compleja
de riesgos y oportunidades yo creo que
todos los actores todos los
intervinientes en este conflicto
ven oportunidades el occidente Ucrania
ven oportunidades el presidente
ucraniano por ejemplo ve en esto una
oportunidad para negociar con sus
aliados más ayuda militar en las
garantías de seguridad de Ucrania cara
por ejemplo a la Cumbre de la otan de
principios de de Julio el occidente o
los aliados occidentales de Ucrania
buscan
debilitar a Rusia
reforzando su estrategia de unidad de
las instituciones euroatlánticas Putin
busca
utilizar este este esta ocurrencia esta
Aventura para subrayar la necesidad de
estabilidad de unidad Cara a la agresión
de occidente como como él siempre dice
que está aconteciendo sucediendo que no
es una guerra entre Rusia Ucrania es una
guerra entre Rusia y occidente
lucashenko Igualmente Busca fortalecer
su posición negocial junto a Rusia
limitar su dependencia y su memorización
cara a Putin o sea es una situación
política muy compleja que tenemos que
mirar desde un punto de vista de riesgos
y oportunidades Es verdad que después de
todos estos días vamos a mirar otra vez
más al frente de guerra y vamos otra vez
a discutir más las armas los
consensos de occidente los peligros
nucleares todo lo que estaba siendo
discutido antes y precisamente para
enfocarnos en el frente de guerra y van
usted Cómo cree que todos estos hechos
puedan impactar en lo que ocurre en
Ucrania y en lugares como bacmut Queen y
pregocen afirmó en abril que ya sus
tropas lo dominaban
la pregunta está dirigida a mí sí
Bueno yo creo que a ver primero tenemos
un balance preliminar de la
contraofensiva ucraniana que no ha
avanzado con la suficiente rapidez y
respuesta a las expectativas tanto de
Ucrania como de occidente esto es un
punto que genera también una reacción
mayor de de parte del gobierno ucraniano
en el sentido de pedir más asistencia
más ayuda para poder avanzar contra las
líneas defensivas de Rusia en el frente
abierto en este momento quiero
recordarles otra cosa con respecto a
magner Wagner es fundamentalmente una
fuerza ofensiva Y si está en Bielorrusia
su capacidad no es para trincherarse
sino para enfrentar un avance de
cualquier tipo bueno Esto genera toda
una situación en términos de cómo va a
seguir desarrollándose el conflicto en
términos de la de la contraofensiva
ucraniana sí estaba avanzar no va a
avanzar hasta dónde puede llegar frente
a las defensas rusas pero también yo
creo que hay un impacto internacional
desde el punto de vista de la
geopolítica que es muy importante aquí
no mencionamos el hecho mencionamos el
hecho de quienes miran la fractura La
debilidad del gobierno de Putin pero no
mencionamos el hecho de quienes sí han
salido a respaldarlo en este caso eh
china ha sido un Vocero de la posición
de que bueno está apoyando a Putin en
mantener la estabilidad y la unidad en
Rusia y esto es un punto fundamental
para entender un poco una dinámica mayor
que excede específicamente lo del Push o
de la guerra en Ucrania y que tiene que
ver con una dinámica de la transición
Global en términos de la aparición de
nuevos actores y de su alineamiento
frente a la alianza Euro Atlántico y ahí
esto Abre una serie de interrogantes Que
obviamente no vamos a discutir acá pero
creo que es importante también entender
como el hecho de la situación de estos
días
repercute en este tipo de alineamientos
y de alianzas en donde lo que estamos
viendo Es que por lo menos Bielorrusia y
China han expresado un Putin muy claro
claro y además esto cambió por primera
vez la postura de China que siempre
había defendido sus políticas
internacionales de respetar la soberanía
de cada país y de no respaldar
abiertamente a Moscú y ahora sí lo hizo
promoviendo la unidad del país tal como
usted lo está lo está explicando Andrés
quiero que usted nos dé su conclusión
entonces de con todos estos elementos en
el panorama Cómo interpretar esta corta
rebelión de banner
como parte de una madeja extremadamente
compleja como lo señaló mi colega en
donde todavía los hilos están
desenredando y no sabemos dónde van a
llegar en todo caso el resultado
concreto a mí me van a ver en este
momento Es que refuerza la posición de
Putin en términos del llamado a la
unidad y a la estabilidad en Rusia cosa
que es un factor fundamental para la
percepción del ruso medio Andrés y cuál
es su conclusión de este panorama tan
complejo que hemos intentado
desanudar un poco acá
bueno Yo diría que
para llamar la atención a lo que me
parece lo más importante es que este
suceso
demuestra la importancia la necesidad de
la paz de llegar a un acuerdo negociado
entre entre todas las partes o sea es
algo muy complejo Que acarreta
demasiado riesgos y demasiados peligros
como para que esta guerra siga
prolongándose sin que las partes vuelvan
a hablar unas con otras yo recuerdo que
aún hoy el papa
está enviando su cardenal putzi creo que
se llama a
Moscú para seguir este camino de
reencuentro entre las partes O sea no de
negociación porque es un proceso de
largo plazo pero de reapramación para
que esas rotos hace un año se puedan
reconstruir y las partes puedan por lo
menos hablar sobre lo que sería unas
unas condiciones de negociación
diplomática o sea yo creo que esto
muestra con muy mucha cuidado la
necesidad de la diplomacia que la
diplomacia vuelva a tener su papel y su
lugar de donde ha sido Sacada por varios
actores hace ya más de un año usted dice
Entonces cómo se muestra la necesidad de
la diplomacia vemos también Cómo se
puede fortalecer la imagen de Putin
sobre todo internamente y también como
Wagner todavía no ha acabado Marcos
Farías Ferreira y Andrés servín gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en el debate de
France 24 y le agradezco también al
equipo técnico quien hizo posible este
este programa la producción estuvo a
cargo de Andrés doncell y la de los
invitados con Tania Herrera sigan en
Franz 24
[Música]